taxes essentially the government's
GoFundMe page now
today is April 15th which means you have
just 45 minutes to file your taxes
except relax don't panic because thanks
to the weekend and a holiday the
deadline is actually April 17th
this year except don't relax do panic
that's still not enough time to do it
right you're you're absolutely
and you're going to jail Anthony
many people are perplexed and mystified
by our tax system perhaps best
exemplified by this Instagram video from
cardi B you know that government is
taking 40 percent of my taxes and Uncle
Sam I want to know what you're doing
with my tax money but why does
y'all doing with my money
what is your with my money I
want to know I want receipts I wants
everything I wanna go to my cousin
weenie
[Applause]
whoa whoa cardi if you really want to
know where your money's going may I
present to you the recently passed
omnibus spending package
[Applause]
because it turns out cardi your
money goes to your military your
health care and your
Social Security and veteran and
unemployment benefits everything else is
just on discretionary and
of course interest now as you may recall
late last year Republicans passed and
Donald Trump signed a tax reform bill
and in selling it Trump made some clear
promises about who stood to benefit our
focus is on helping the folks who work
in the mail rooms and the machine shops
of America the plumbers the carpenters
the cops the teachers the truck drivers
the pipe fitters the people that like me
best well that that is clearly nonsense
because if this bill were really helping
the people that like Donald Trump best
it would exclusively benefit
Eric Trump Roseanne Barr and anyone
who's ever looked both ways before
whispering it was the choose and the
truth is for all chumps talk of pipe
fitters the biggest tax rate cuts by far
actually goes to businesses with the top
federal corporate tax rate the tax on a
company's profits going from thirty five
percent to just twenty one percent and
to be fair many policymakers on both
sides had argued at the 35 percent
federal rate among the highest in the
world
should actually come down but to be even
fairer most companies didn't pay thirty
five percent in fact before the bill was
signed to the effective rate the amount
companies actually paid was closer to
twenty four percent and some large
companies have historically paid far
less than that
you may remember a few years ago people
were furious about this ge had profits
of fourteen point two billion dollars in
2010 five billion dollars of that made
in the United States but the company's
expected US tax bill a grand total of
zero dollars okay so when the total is
zero you can't call it a grand total
there is literally no total less grand
except maybe total cereal and that's
just because it tastes like your spoon
somehow missed the cereal and now you're
just eating the box that it came in
and GE may well say we'll hold on that's
just one year but a recent study found
that between 2008 and 2015 18 large
profitable companies including General
Electric paid no federal income tax at
all over the entire period not at all
and that is a staggering total which is
incidentally what they used to call
total with raisins until they got more
honest who changed it to total with
raises but who gives a
so tonight in honor of upcoming tax day
we thought we'd give you just a glimpse
of the lengths that companies will go to
to legally avoid taxes both here and
abroad
now corporate tax avoidance has a long
and infuriatingly proud history in the
1980s for instance a lawyer named John
Carroll jr. came up with a tactic to
move US companies offshore to avoid
taxes and his firm celebrated him with
and this is true a 13-minute operator
staged in his New York apartment and
I'll give you just a very small taste
[Music]
Wow
we may have just found the only musical
resistant to race blind casting you
can't go Hamilton on this one because
those people really have to be white now
now that the tax dodge being celebrated
they're involved taking an American
company and headquarter in it in Panama
where taxes were lower something its
creator called the Panama scoot which
sounds like the name of a tiny elf in a
cowboy hat
my name's Panama scoot and I sleep in
your boots and offshore scooting is
actually something of a common theme in
corporate tax avoidance for decades
companies have hunted for ways to get
their money to friendlier tax havens
like the Cayman Islands you may remember
that during the 2012 election it emerged
that Mitt Romney had money in the in
companies in the Caymans which led to
this magnificent clip of John Stossel
saying the one thing he probably
shouldn't be saying to the person he's
speaking to but Romney pays taxes and
all the money earned from the cayman
entities i would think it would be like
pirate heaven some pirates can't say the
word pirates
to a guy with an eyepatch it can't it's
not fair
it's like me sitting down across from
you and calling you bootleg Geraldo yes
yes it's obvious but it's also lazy and
hurtful that's an indoor thought and tax
havens have become magnets to
corporations who try and shift as much
of their profits there as possible it's
a major reason why in 2016
nearly two-thirds of the profits made by
American multinationals outside the US
were booked in just six low or zero tax
countries and it's a lot easier to move
profits offshore than you might think an
increasingly popular way particularly
pharmaceutical and high-tech companies
like Google avoid paying the 35% is to
shift their patents computer code pill
formulas even logos from their US bases
to their outposts in low tax countries
today
a company can move automatically all of
its assets just on paper you can push a
button and move your algorithms you know
could take the recipe out of the vault
yeah put it in a Swiss Fault and then
and then it's Swiss yep coke could put
that recipe in a Swiss vault and their
profits would move offshore that is very
roughly how it works although for the
record just being in a Swiss vault
doesn't automatically make something
Swiss that's why we don't call this
Swiss gold we call it Nazi gold
those are Hitler bucks your Swiss
and this this happens all the time
and the best innovators in weasely
accounting have arguably been tech
companies look at Apple for years
they've been deferring paying US taxes
on foreign profits by stashing the money
overseas and not bringing it back so
much so that at the end of last year
they had 269 billion dollars parked
overseas and when their CEO Tim Cook
appeared in front of Congress a few
years back he was very defensive about
that
we pay all the taxes we owe every single
dollar we don't move intellectual
property offshore and use it to sell our
products back to the United States to
avoid taxes we don't stash money on some
Caribbean island now he was technically
correct there because Apple didn't stash
their money on a Caribbean island they
did however have it stashed on this
island Ireland which is it is true not
in the Caribbean so one word made a lot
of difference there it's like if
somebody said the one thing I can
promise you is that this refrigerator is
absolutely not
full of severed Caribbean heads maybe
that is technically true but I'm still
going to pass on a sparkling water and
when Ireland indicated that it planned
to change its tax laws Apple found a new
shelter for profits on this island the
Isle of Jersey a tax haven in the
English Channel which is again not
technically in the Caribbean although
when you really look at it you could
almost mistake it for the Caribbean if
you squint a little drink 9 points of
beer and hold a picture of the Caribbean
in front of us
meanwhile Google used a slightly
different tax workaround sending its
money on something of a world tour
Google license some of the intellectual
property it created here in the US to a
subsidiary in Ireland but it turns out
Google's overseas profits don't even get
taxed there because Google then
reportedly funnels those profits through
the Netherlands and then to of all
places Bermuda where the corporate tax
rate is zero now that tax trick actually
has a name it's called the double Irish
with a dutch sandwich it sounds like a
disgusting sex act or an even more
disgusting Waffle House menu item it's
it's when someone opens up a baked
potato farce in it and closes it again
really quick that's one of it that
that's that is exactly what it is and
when Google CFO was asked about their
tax policies at a conference his answer
nearly got him laughed off the stage we
pay our taxes in every jurisdiction to
the full extent that the law allows us
and that's what we do we pay every penny
of tax we owe to everybody everywhere ok
the reaction to the sentence I pay all
my taxes should never be incredulous
laughter unless you are a very wealthy
dog who's just spoken for the first time
and here is where I have some good news
and some bad news the good news is that
Trump's tax bill actually forces
companies to pay taxes on all the money
they've stashed overseas the hope is
that they'll then bring it home in
something called repatriation the bad
news is the tax they're being forced to
pay which may have once been 35%
remember has been slashed to as little
as eight to 15% which seems less like a
punishment and a lot more like actively
rewarding companies for tax avoidance
but Steve minuchin
Treasury secretary an objectively
good-looking man argues that this would
be a huge benefit to America's workers
we will have a one-time tax on overseas
profits which will bring back trillions
of dollars that are offshore to be
invested here in the United States to
purchase capital and to create jobs now
I know it was hard to pay attention to
what he was saying because you were just
automatically undressing
to go with your eyes and you do it
whenever he opens his mouth I'm all
right I'm definitely right the guy's a
California ten
he's a smoke show but but what he's
saying there is giving these companies a
break on the taxes they owe is worth it
because it will lead to job creation and
that is hard to completely disprove
because anything theoretically could
lead to jobs you can say I'm dipping
this badger in fudge to create jobs and
I can't prove that you won't create any
jobs by doing that but I would argue
that if creating jobs is your main goal
there are probably better ways to do it
now luckily we actually have the benefit
of a test case here because in 2004 we
basically did the exact same thing under
the American Jobs Creation Act it
offered a one-year tax holiday where
companies could bring back overseas
profits and just a five percent tax
rates the idea was that they would then
create jobs but when the Senate looked
at the employment numbers of the 15
companies that brought back the most
money this is what they found
these are the average numbers of US jobs
at those companies over a five year span
here is where the big supposedly
job-creating tax holiday kicked in and
that is pretty underwhelming I
would argue that's the most useless
ineffective holiday since Arbor Day and
I'm sorry Arbor Day but your secretaries
day for trees and we all need to accept
that in fact instead of hiring workers
across the board companies mostly
rewarded their shareholders using 94
cents out of every dollar they brought
home on stock buybacks and dividends
something you can read about in the
best-selling book yeah no
they did that by acclaimed author
everyone who knows anything about
corporations and look for many of those
companies that may have been the best
use of their money there is no point in
hiring people that you don't need
but the Trump administration is fiercely
insisting that this time their tax
holiday is already creating jobs and
some companies have seemed happy to pay
along play-along Apple put out a press
release not long after the tax bill was
signed titled Apple accelerates US
investment and job creation bragging
they were about to create over 20,000
new jobs and Trump was quick to take
credit President Trump tweeting in
response quote I promised that my
policies would allow companies like
Apple to bring mass
of amounts of money back to the United
States great to see Apple follow through
as a result of tax cuts all caps okay
first that is a solid read from Jake
Tapper there in fact I think all anchors
should be forced to shout whenever Trump
uses all caps in tweets I'll show you
this morning the president announced
that he was quote heading to see the
border wall prototypes in California or
today today the president wished all
Americans are happy Easter but but for
all the Trump's excitement those 20,000
Apple jobs were probably going to happen
anyway given that the hole was entirely
consistent with what Apple was doing in
the United States before the tax cut
bill passed and Tim Cook knows this this
is how he responded when asked just how
much of his hiring spree was down to
Trump's new tax plan there are large
parts of this that a result of the tax
reform and there's large parts of this
that we would have done in in any
situation and so I haven't spent a lot
of time in categorizing those two
because to me this is about America it's
not about which bucket you put things in
yeah but actually it does matter which
bucket you put things in because I would
rather put things in a bucket labeled
smart economic policy than one labeled
put money in here I like money thanks
dummies Tim Cook and look look there are
legitimate debates over how and how much
we should tax corporate profits but we
just had a huge chance to reform our tax
code and we absolutely blew it because
effective tax reform is not just about
lowering rates
it's about closing loopholes for
instance one reasonable idea raised last
year was forcing companies to pay a
minimum tax in every single country they
operate in it's a bit complicated but
that may well have reduced their abuse
of tax havens but that proposal never
even got out of committee so the result
here is that our tax code is still full
of loopholes and however much Trump
talked about how tax reform would
benefit cops and pipefitters
it's worth knowing that once he got
behind closed doors his message seemed
to change
we're told the president is still
celebrating passage of the Republican
tax cut bill sources with firsthand
which tells CBS News that he told a
group of wealthy people at his exclusive
mar-a-lago estate quote you all just got
a lot richer that's right so on Tuesday
as you scrape together your taxes and
like cardi B wonder what Uncle Sam is
doing with your money rest
assured that Donald Trump's tax reform
continues to let companies engage in
sophisticated tax avoidance schemes and
to those companies I say this on behalf
of America please enjoy this double
Irish with a Dutch sandwich I made it bu
myself eat it while it's hot
[Applause]
you